[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión iniciamos
en el espacio porque llegaron a la
estación espacial china los últimos tres
taconautas que ayudaron en la
construcción de la instalación se trata
de la misión 15 y esta será la primera
ocasión en la que se realiza una
rotación de tripulación es decir la
misión 14 recibió en el espacio a los
integrantes de la quince y Son ellos los
que despedirán a sus compañeros que
llevan casi seis meses en el espacio
el vuelo espacial es un vínculo de
conexión significativo entre la
construcción total de la estación
espacial y el inicio de una nueva fase
de la aplicación y desarrollo de la
instalación en el espacio exterior la
tripulación de la 15 presenciará el
momento en el que el pueblo chino cumpla
el sueño de completar la construcción de
su propia estación que permita continuar
realizando nuevas contribuciones a
construir el poderío chino en el espacio
y la exploración del universo
recordemos que en 2022 se cumplieron los
30 años del programa espacial chino en
1992 los expertos chinos formularon la
idea de construir un laboratorio orbital
tripulado algo que era una fantasía pero
por ello Se elaboró la llamada
estrategia de tres pasos el primero
consistió en enviar taiconautas al
espacio y garantizar su regreso seguro
el segundo desarrollar técnicas y
tecnologías avanzadas de vuelo espacial
incluidas actividades extravehiculares y
acoplamiento orbital el tercero que
ahora está a punto de completarse fue
ensamblar y operar una estación espacial
tripulada permanente algo que marca un
importante hito para China
y ahora seguimos en el espacio pero
vamos a hablar de la misión artemis
recordemos que la primera versión de
este programa fue lanzada al espacio el
pasado 16 de noviembre con el objetivo
de probar todos los componentes para que
en un futuro pueda llevar astronautas a
orbitar la luna y alunizar tras 50 años
de la última misión Apolo pues tras diez
días de recorrido la cápsula abrión
logró un récord al alcanzar una
distancia de 401 mil kilómetros de la
tierra previamente la marca la tenía la
misión Apolo 13 de 1970 con 400 mil
kilómetros y Pese a que este ya es un
hito importante dos días después la nave
se ubicó a la máxima distancia prevista
para esta misión más de 430 mil
kilómetros de nuestro planeta desde el
25 de noviembre la nave entró en la
llamada órbita retrógrada lo que
significa que está viajando alrededor de
la luna en dirección opuesta a la que
lleva el satélite alrededor de la tierra
los expertos explican que la misión está
Rompiendo las expectativas que se tenían
se eligió esta órbita porque es
extremadamente estable no cuesta mucho
combustible mantener su posición allí y
eso le da a todos nuestros ingenieros a
nuestros controladores de vuelo la
oportunidad de aprender realmente sobre
los sistemas de orión en el espacio
profundo aprender a volar una nave
espacial más lejos de lo que jamás
hayamos enviado una destinada a humanos
vamos más allá de cualquier lugar al que
hayamos sido y por lo tanto estaremos en
esta órbita probaremos todos esos
sistemas eventualmente haremos una
maniobra para salir de allí haremos otro
sobrevuelo y volveremos a casa el
regreso de artemiso no está previsto
para el 11 de diciembre con un amerizaje
frente a la costa de California en el
océano Pacífico después de un viaje de
25 días y alrededor de 11 horas
pues volvemos a la Tierra y vamos a
hablar de una iniciativa que puede
parecer bastante particular futurista e
incluso algo descabellada se trata de
201 cuerpos humanos y 120 de mascotas
que están criogenizados en las
instalaciones del laboratorio alcohol
extension Life en pleno desierto de
Arizona
el proceso requiere llegar al paciente
inmediatamente después de su muerte
legal en el cuerpo casi a temperatura de
congelamiento reiniciar la circulación
para que llegue sangre más fría al
cerebro e interrumpir el flujo de
medicamentos para proteger las células
luego transportamos el cuerpo a nuestras
instalaciones y hacemos procedimientos
para llegar a los vasos sanguíneos y
reemplazamos tanta sangre y otros
fluidos como sea posible con una
solución especial que puede llegar más
abajo Que las temperaturas de
congelamiento sin formar cristales de
hielo Entonces trasladamos al paciente
al lugar donde quedará almacenado y
estará en un líquido en movimiento a 196
grados Celsius bajo cero el primer
cuerpo llegó a las instalaciones en 1976
cabe aclarar que son personas que
fallecieron y cuya esperanza es que
cuando la ciencia avance lo suficiente
pueda curar sus enfermedades y ellos
puedan volver a la vida la iniciativa
tiene un costo de 200 mil dólares por
criogenizar el cuerpo entero y 80,000
por el cerebro
los llamamos pacientes cuando están
criogenizados porque necesitan cuidados
esta gente no está muerta Es verdad que
no están vivos porque no metabolizan lo
caminan pero no están muertos porque
desde nuestro punto de vista no estás
muerto Hasta que el cerebro se deteriora
Y los recuerdos que forman tu
personalidad están completamente
destruidos y nunca pueden ser
recuperados pero mientras que el cerebro
está intacto y detengamos su daño
Esperamos que en el futuro con
tecnología más avanzada se pueda reparar
el cerebro revertir el envejecimiento y
volver a la vida
ahora un dato que vale la pena conocer
es que en California en 2016
investigadores del centro Twenty First
Century medicine descongelaron con éxito
el cerebro de un conejo de un estado
criogénico en un estado casi perfecto
usando nanotecnología si bien el cerebro
no era funcional así llegamos al final
de esta Crónica ustedes Les agradecemos
su sintonía continúen con nosotros que
hay más en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]